[Música]
más de un millón de personas están sin
servicio de electricidad en Estados
Unidos debido a la tormenta invernal que
azota al país 7000 vuelos han sido
cancelados recientemente el estado de
Nueva York decretó el estado de
emergencia
7000 hectáreas arrasadas unas 200
viviendas destruidas y dos fallecidos
dejan hasta el momento los incendios que
afectan la ciudad de viña del mar en
Chile debido a las altas temperaturas
del verano el gobierno decretó el estado
de catástrofe
y en Argentina la oposición política
presentará una denuncia penal contra el
presidente Alberto Fernández esto
después de que el mandatario se negara a
acatar un fallo de la Corte Suprema que
lo obliga a restituir fondos al gobierno
de la ciudad de Buenos Aires
Hola Bienvenidos a este informativo de
France 24 en el que hacemos énfasis en
los temas de nuestro continente el
continente americano vamos a comenzar en
Estados Unidos allí el comité del
Congreso que Investiga el ataque al
Capitolio del 6 de enero del 2021
publicó su informe final se trata de más
de 800 páginas en las que detalla como
el presidente Donald Trump intentó
anular los resultados de las elecciones
del 2020 y describe al ex mandatario
como la causa central de los hechos
además recomienda crear un mecanismo
para que Trump no vuelva a ocupar cargos
públicos justo cuando se prepara para
ser candidato en el 2024 Andrés Meza
Muñoz tiene los detalles
son 18 meses de investigación plasmados
en más de 800 páginas que concluyen que
la causa central del ataque al Capitolio
del 6 de enero de 2021 fue un hombre el
expresidente Donald Trump parte de la
tragedia del seis de enero es la
conducta de quienes sabían que lo que
pasó estuvo profundamente mal y sin
embargo trataron de restarle importancia
a minimizarlo o defender a los
responsables el documento de Ocho
capítulos detalla los esfuerzos de Trump
para anular las elecciones de 2020 en
las que fue Derrotado y así bloquear la
transferencia de poder por ello el
comité ya había pedido a los fiscales
acusar al ex mandatario de cuatro
delitos incitación a la insurrección
obstrucción de un procedimiento oficial
del Congreso intento de fraude a Estados
Unidos y conspiración para presentar
falsos testimonios y en una serie de
recomendaciones piden al congreso
considerar la creación de un mecanismo
que evite que Trump pueda volver a
ocupar cargos públicos justo al
expresidente se prepara para volver a
ser candidato a la presidencia en 2024
ningún hombre que se comporte de esa
manera en ese momento puede volver a
ocupar un puesto de autoridad en nuestra
nación no es apto para ningún cargo El
documento se da en unos días tensos para
Trump se espera que pronto la cámara de
representantes publique sus
declaraciones de impuestos después de
haber intentado ocultarlas durante años
pues justamente El Congreso de Estados
Unidos aprobó el presupuesto para el año
fiscal 2023 los fondos para gastar
alcanzan ya los 1,7 billones de dólares
dentro de los cuales están los 45.000
millones destinados para la ayuda de
Ucrania la cámara de representantes dio
su visto bueno a ese proyecto de ley
esto tiene lugar solo un día después de
que el senado de mayoría demócrata lo
hubiera validado evitando así un cierre
del Gobierno Federal
y seguimos en Estados Unidos porque un
juez de la ciudad de Miami determinó que
Alex saab Aliado del gobierno de Nicolás
maduro en Venezuela no tiene derecho a
la inmunidad diplomática en Estados
Unidos así las cosas saab deberá ser
juzgado por lavado de dinero el juez
añadió que la evidencia y también los
testimonios respaldan la tesis de que
maduro y su gobierno manipularon
documentos para que esa app pareciera
que viajaba a Irán como enviado especial
cuando fue arrestado en Cabo verde
maduro ha exigido la liberación del
empresario como parte del acercamiento
con Washington
y vamos a seguir en Estados Unidos
porque la tormenta invernal que afecta
buena parte del territorio del país ha
llevado a que las autoridades indicaron
que más de un millón de personas
quedaron sin servicio de Electricidad y
más de 7.000 vuelos ya fueron cancelados
los meteorólogos advierten sobre el
peligro que representa este inusual
fenómeno climático el informe es de
Rafael Pérez
una tormenta de nieve única en una
generación así calificó el National
Weather Service el fenómeno
meteorológico que potencialmente
afectará a más de 240 millones de la
población estadounidense las imágenes
satelitales muestran grandes masas de
aire sobre la Unión Americana alrededor
de siete mil vuelos fueron cancelados
causando caos de Cara a la celebración
de Nochebuena
nos preocupa mucho que los vuelos se
retrasen o se cancelen afortunadamente
ese no es el caso hasta ahora pero he
estado ansiosa por traer a nuestra
familia aquí a tiempo tratando de ver a
la familia que no hemos visto en muchos
años debido al covid y las carreteras
tampoco son ajenas al problema los
conductores se enfrentan a una
visibilidad casi nula en la víspera al
presidente Joe biden advirtió de la
magnitud de La tempestad en una sesión
informativa
por favor tómense esta tormenta muy en
serio Yo no sé si sus jefes los dejarán
pero si todos tienen planes de viaje
váyanse ahora no es
más de 1,25 millones de personas se
quedaron sin electricidad igual de
afectada se vio la paquetería por correo
en este sentido la empresa FedEx afirmó
que habría retrasos en las entregas a
nivel nacional para el sábado se espera
mejoras en las condiciones
meteorológicas a medida que la masa de
aire se desplace hacia el este
en la ciudad de viña del mar en Chile
las altas temperaturas del verano han
provocado incendios que han arrasado con
cerca de 7000 hectáreas también con 200
viviendas y han dejado dos personas
fallecidas las conflagraciones que se
mantienen activas por lo tanto el
gobierno ha tenido que decretar el
estado de catástrofe en esa zona del
país el reporte es de Andrés triviño
las altas temperaturas en Chile generan
estragos los residentes de viña del mar
en la costa central del país limpian los
daños de un gran incendio mientras las
llamas se mantienen vivas y afectan a
cientos de personas y hogares el
gobierno central decretó el estado de
catástrofe en la zona ordenaron subir a
todo andaba buscando una amiga
desaparecía pero no la puedo encontrar
es un caos es un caos esto una ola de
calor que ha azotado a Chile con
temperaturas récord en algunas zonas y
la falta de lluvias ha intensificado los
incendios forestales que ya han quemado
más de 7000 hectáreas en menos de una
semana
las autoridades calculan que entre 200 y
500 casas estarían afectadas por las
llamas en Viña del Mar Por lo cual han
desplegado helicópteros y aviones
cisterna además de brigadas terrestres
Bueno tengo tenemos Pérdida total O sea
la familia yo la tengo tan de mi papá
que está más abajo Así que vine a ver
perdimos todo todo se puede decir
documento perdimos vehículo lo que son
unas perrita que se me quedaron hecho
así que están por ahí están Están
muertas afectadas las casas de mi suegra
la casa de mis amigos
bueno se perdió todo
los bomberos han informado que las
condiciones climáticas actuales podrían
contribuir a que el incendio sea
controlado prontamente
y hay tensión política en Argentina
luego de que la oposición presentara una
denuncia penal contra el presidente
Alberto Fernández La medida tiene lugar
después de que el mandatario se negara a
acatar un fallo de la Corte Suprema que
lo obliga a restituir fondos al gobierno
de la ciudad de Buenos Aires gobierno
que está en manos de la oposición
Valentina Torres Sánchez nos cuenta más
A solo días de terminar los festejos
mundialistas la política devolvió la
atención y la polarización Argentina la
Corte Suprema de Justicia ordenó al
gobierno nacional que entregue unos 997
millones de dólares adicionales a la
ciudad de Buenos Aires que provienen de
los impuestos recaudados por el fisco se
trata de los llamados coparticipables
que se entregan entre las provincias y
la capital según una tabla de
porcentajes establecida por la ley en
2016 el entonces presidente Mauricio
macri aumento por decreto la suma que
recibía la ciudad de Buenos Aires del
1,40% al
3,75%. esto justo cuando el gobierno
local quedaba en manos de Horacio
Rodríguez larreta su delfín político
posteriormente en 2020 el actual jefe de
estado Alberto Fernández recortó Los
fondos a la capital del 3,75 al 2,32% y
ahora la corte dictaminó que pasen al
2,95% Fernández aseguró que no acatará
la resolución en un día aciago para el
federalismo por este fallo
tremendo que ha sacado la corte que
genera una enorme desigualdad
entre la ciudad más suculenta del país y
el resto del país la decisión de
Fernández generó un fuerte revuelo entre
la oposición la coalición cívica ya
presentó una demanda penal por
alzamiento desobediencia judicial abuso
de autoridad y violación de los deberes
de funcionario público el presidente
pidió presentó una recusación contra los
jueces de la corte para que no
participen en este proceso
Esto no es contra la ciudad esto es
contra la Constitución nacional
expertos aseguran que la decisión De no
respetar el fallo sí incumple la
Constitución y sectores de la oposición
ya consideran pedir un juicio político
contra Fernández
es todo en las noticias siga con
nosotros
[Música]